welcome everyone my name is Lisa Norberg
I'm the Dean of the Barnard College
Library and Information Services and I'm
delighted to be here today to introduce
the fifth of six events in the research
without borders series for the 2010-11
academic year sponsored by the scholarly
communications program I'll introduce
our speakers today each will speak for
about 20 minutes and then we'll have
time for discussion and questions from
the audience we are videotaping the
event so if you have a question for our
panel we ask that you use the microphone
in the middle of the room it is my great
pleasure to introduce today's speakers
Charles Watts caen is director of purdue
university press a unit of purdue
university libraries he previously
worked as director of publications at
the American School of classical studies
he has over 15 years of experience in
various scholarly publishing roles and
is a member of the Executive Board of
the Society for scholarship scholarly
publishing and of the library Relations
Committee of the Association of American
University presses he is currently
working on an IMLS funded research
project on strategies for success in
library based publishing Monica
McCormick is program a fish officer for
digital scholarly publishing and leads
the office for digital scholarly
publishing at New York University she
reports jointly to the division of
libraries and to un and new NYU press
she worked for more than 15 years at the
University of California Press mainly as
an acquiring editor in the humanities
she received her ms LS in 2006 she hopes
to find ways to unite the distinct but
compatible skills of publishers and
those of librarians and technologists to
support sustainable scholarly
communication oddly enough her bio fails
to mention a certain information
services course she took Annie fall of
2005 which i believe was life altering
her
Monica but I guess you can't include
everything Maria bond is the associate
university librarian for publishing at
the University of Michigan library her
position was created to oversee the
library's growing suite of publishing
and scholarly communication initiatives
which include the university of michigan
press and the scholarly publishing
office she serves as an advisor to the
university community on issues
surrounding scholarly publishing and
communication policy and supports
innovative projects in those areas both
in and out of the library please help me
welcome our panel well thank you very
much Lisa and it's a real pleasure and
an honor to be here from the wilds of
the Midwest where the snow melted last
well yesterday so it's very nice to have
this opportunity to talk about
campus-based publishing and I'm going to
talk about a few things I'm going to
start with a few words about the wider
context of library based publishing move
on to what we're doing at Purdue and
then I have threes of case studies which
I hope illustrate some of the points I'm
going to make so I'd first like to give
a little bit of context that comes from
some work we're doing with colleagues at
university of utah and georgia tech with
the support of IMLS and the this is a
collaborative planning grant under the
national leadership grant scheme with
the name library publishing services
strategies for success and as you may
know the collaborative planning grants
are preparing Terry they're meant to be
informing directions for the future so
the aim of this particular project is to
take stock
of what's going on in library based
publishing about three years after
several important reports many of which
you'll know as particularly the report
by Callahan for ARL on research library
publishing and to really take an
evidence-based approach to the next
phase of capacity building in this area
it it's an activity that has several
stages the first one was a web survey
which we started in October last year
and finished off at the end of end of
the year and many of the people in this
room were very very helpful in
completing this horrible survey which
was took about an hour although we
pretended it took 20 minutes and so
we're very grateful for that we had we
surveyed members of ARL all ARL
institutions oberlin group institutions
and university library group
institutions university library group of
course is sort of a number of private
institutions mid-sized libraries ARL the
largest and opening group was meant to
represent a lot of the smaller
institutions so what we are trying to do
there is get a good sample of different
types of library we also doing three
case studies one at each member
institution and those are being
performed by done by raincrow who many
of you will know who is a consultant to
spark as well as a business consultant
for many projects in scholarly
publishing and he has been to Purdue he
has focused at Purdue on a journal and
sustainability and business modeling in
the e-journal space he's in Atlanta this
week at Georgia Tech looking at
conference proceedings and publishing
that kind of symposium and proceedings
product and then he finishes off in Utah
looking at book like publications so
that includes technical reports as well
as monographs and then finally in May
will be holding
three workshops one at each member
institution and those are to bring
together the people who completed the
survey the best but also people who
we've learned about through the through
the whole research process who we feel
have interesting things to say but the
other thing about those is that we're
trying to get a good sample of different
types of libraries and different types
of roles within those libraries so
people haven't been invited are not not
interesting people it's just that we're
trying to get that sample and there's a
URL where you can find out more about
this and we're going to be putting up
the list of speakers of those workshops
quite soon at the spark partnering
website so these are some very initial
results from that web survey which we
completed and you'll see at the top sort
of the headline figure out which Carla
Han came up with which caused a bit of a
stir back in 2008 which was at
sixty-five percent of ARL institutions
were either doing or considering
publishing and that figure has come up
again and again in various reports in
the web survey that we've done we head
around the same number of ARL
institutions answering and it looks as
if it's now about seven seventy eight
percent of ARL institutions are either
doing or considering publishing so there
is some growth and only twenty-two
percent of the institutions were not
active at all in this area it's a it's a
difficult number because publishing is a
very broad term but it's interesting to
see growth as I mentioned we were also
looking at what was happening in smaller
institutions and you'll see that of the
Oberlin group members so mostly liberal
arts colleges only twenty-eight percent
are active in this area and across all
the groups fifty-six percent said they
were active
if one assumes that the people who
didn't respond read and have publishing
programs and that's even a smaller
amount 37 sent but they may just got
sick of our long survey so we're not
sure about that this is just another um
sort of another feature of the survey we
asked to ask the respondents to explain
why they'd started or why they were
considering publishing services and to
check all that apply with a pre-selected
list and I think what's interesting here
is to show that this is not just a
mission related activity for libraries
to change the established scholarly
publishing system but there's also
definite demand on campuses that they're
responding to from faculty students and
administration and then the twenty one
percent cited other if overlapping
reasons this was just a free text field
just a couple of other things since
we're talking today partly about
collaboration thirty-two percent of ARL
libraries are participating in a
collaborative project project with
University Press we asked what kind of
project that might be and most of those
projects are digitizing out of print
monographs and this is interesting to me
because Callahan found thirty one
percent of ARL libraries back in 2007
during collaboration so this really it
strikes me that this has not really
grown as an activity and I think the
University Press community may be partly
responsible for that and resistant to it
and then finally there's there was back
in 2007 this report from Africa
University publishing in a digital age
only eleven percent of University Press
directors reported to deans of libraries
most reported up to the provost and
that's grown slightly seventeen percent
of University Press directors now report
to the heads of libraries so just in
that context I just wanted to talk a
little bit about the organizational
situation of Purdue University these are
just some facts and figures about Purdue
in the middle of a field a land-grant
institution which is a public
institution
I want to just point out particularly
the fact that this is a very focused
University it does have humanities and
Social Sciences but it's really a
land-grant institution focusing on
science technology agricultural
engineering and areas like aeronautical
engineering in particular the University
Press is part of the libraries in its
had a reporting relationship for many
years but this really became a much more
focused relationship in 2009 when the
press was moved physically from the
margins of campus next to the public
relations and the information people
right into the heart of the library so
it's moved to a space which is just
above library administration next to the
information technology department very
close to everything that's going on
around scholarly communication and that
was a decision made by the Dean Jim
Mullins but it came in to the libraries
as a pretty traditional press very book
focused 25 to 30 books a year very small
it's an aaup group one press under 1.5
million in net sales which is
characteristically percent of aaup
presses over fifty percent and it had
one odd feature which is that since 2006
the press had started publishing open
access journals using the library's
digital Commons platform and so now we
have 10 open access journals small
journals mostly faculty founded but they
do quite well and the last point here
non-aligned strings heard you actually
does have strengths in these areas in
Jewish Studies and Central European
history and so on but you'll see that
that's really not aligned with where the
university focuses its attention in its
funding which is on areas of science and
technology and engineering and
agriculture and that's a point on going
to continue with so this is just yo the
web page of the press and you'll see the
Jewish Jesus hugo von Hoffman style from
Birkin Wordsworth to the modern sublime
in Chinese literature so just to reel
also point that these are not what you
would expect to see from a large
stem-based University so the part of the
libraries where there's most
collaboration most opportunity for
collaboration with the press is in the
area of repository services there was
this idea of a scholar being at the
universities libraries repository
service umbrella split down into epubs
er caves and e data that was a good idea
it's not necessarily being carried
through and I'm going to focus on epubs
which is what to run on digital Commons
er caves is still run on content DM and
II data is really a work in progress
although we're finally making some good
headway there on the data side epubs is
staffed by one FTE the digital
collections librarian mark newton and
with digital Commons we're able of
course to outsource the technical
activities of running that platform to
Berkeley electronic press Eddie kit
makes it quite a powerful publishing
service as well and I think that's a
great advantage of digital Commons that
you have the same workflow tools as ve
press users for their own journals and
here's a picture of epubs and you'll see
the pedal University Press has a
community there and in there you'll find
these ten Eternals you'll find some
backlist monographs open access and you
will find the couple of other things but
quite a small community so here in 2008
was the problem and this is what I'm
going to devote the main remainder of my
minutes to so for the press our problem
was that lists were not aligned with the
university strengths as a very small
press there's a lack of digital
expertise and capacity to respond to the
growing interest of faculty were showing
in things digital grown interest by 2008
and basically the press was pretty
irrelevant to most of the institution it
was not well known about for the
libraries and for purdue heat pumps in
particular
there is this problem that all
repositories or most repositories were
having back then of lack of faculty
participation as depositors there is
nothing in it for the faculty in terms
of what they get out of depositing just
mark sitting there trying to provide
services and not really able to bride
services even though he's being asked
for them so he could provide the
infrastructure but not really the
services to support that so faculty
would have to do a lot themselves and
some difficulty in articulating what the
repository was for which I think was
common back then and possibly still is
in some cases so this is a slide that I
found very useful as a sort of a
thinking tool for thinking about how the
press and the libraries can collaborate
and particularly epubs it's a slide that
started with jg bank a who's the CEO of
b e press and what it shows is it shows
this continuum of faculty needs faculty
and staff needs in the digital
environment for all kinds of things not
just books and journals but all kinds of
different products the blue stars are
areas where perhaps the Purdue epubs in
the libraries and have the have the
skills and can provide the best services
the red stars are areas where the press
can potentially add value and in many
cases a blue star is overlain with a red
star so for example if you think of a
conference you can see an electronic
presentation of an conference hosted by
the libraries and then a more digested
form of a conference in maybe an edited
book done by the press so I like this I
like this slide as a way of showing that
we operate across a continuum and by
doing things together we can provide
more in that continuum than each
operating independently and I'd like to
now just talk about three case studies
very briefly these are areas of
importance to the University which the
press was previously not operating in
which we are now able to operate in and
provide some services to the faculty in
and and these are these are areas
I'm of importance and I call this slide
from collaboration to integration
because as I'll show we started in a
small way and then we've moved on to
things which are much more integrated
and where it's hard to say which part is
the press in which part of the library's
the two entities are bringing skills to
the table but it's a joint project civil
engineering building construction very
strong areas at Purdue and what we
started doing with the libraries is we
were doing books at the press in sort of
niche areas mainly with building
construction management which is a
number one department in the country
down that mini department but it is it
is a very good department and what we
were doing was we are putting
supplementary materials on epubs and
here you see some spreadsheets which are
printed in the demolition book but you
can download them and you can manipulate
them and use them from epubs but now so
this is the collaboration now we're
moving to work much more closely and
this is a project the JT RP joint
transportation research program funded
by the Indiana Department of
Transportation based at Purdue it's been
active since 1930s and we're now working
with Jay trp to do things which library
like but also things which are
publishing like with their digital with
their technical reports so you can see a
list of things and Lib you know there's
a library roll and press there's a
publishing roll being able to bundle
together all these services we can
provide what what this group needs and
you'll see a sample report up their
citizens band radio communication so
this is just some guys sitting in a car
by the edge of i-65 and being monitored
by the JD RP who are describing who are
then transcribing their activities and
you'll see digital comments as a little
widget so you can plot it on a Google
map and so on so here here's something
where India the in dot through JT RP is
providing funding for a naught point 5
FTE production editor within the press
and also providing funding for some
digitization work by the libraries and
we think it's an interesting project
here's another area where the press has
had a very strong list this is the
relationship between pets and people but
that comes continues into areas of
therapy dogs and and public policy
there's a slide which I didn't put up
which is about the New York poop scoop
law for example we have a book on that
and you can see here the collaboration
with the libraries was limited to
putting some older books up open access
in digital Commons so the ecology of
stray dogs but now in this area we're
moving towards much more integrated
approach which is a project which I'm
very excited by which is being called
habari central human animal bond
research initiative central and this is
hopefully launching later this year were
launched in 2012 and it's part
bibliography it's part of sort of a
digital library and of course we're
inspired here by things like Columbia
International Affairs online and the
long civil rights movement work at UNC
but it's got parts in here library staff
time being funded by this foundation
supported project so you'll see in year
one actually no these are continuing in
year one there's actually more of a
librarian to do the bibliography there's
a taxonomy for the field repository and
so on so here's another project where
the library and the press can bring much
more to the table and the presses skills
in project management and and in
original publishing are brought in
through the journal and the coordination
role and finally um information literacy
is a big issue it purred you and it's
not just a library thing it's something
that the Provost believes very strongly
in the last prophet said you know
plagiarism is the biggest problem facing
this university so this is a situation
where we've been working to produce a
journal pedo undergraduate research and
I'm just indicating with the red arrows
that librarians are very involved with
this editorial board but also in terms
of working with the stew
authors producing training materials
using this as a learning opportunity in
the area of publication ethics so again
this is a funded model for the first
three years and then hopefully touch
wood it will be picked up by the
University and adopted as a core thing
and we have a good we believe that it's
going to happen so just conclude you
know this all looks very rosy but we're
definitely as we grow this project we're
running into some issues and these are
some things we're thinking about the
brand and reputation issue from the
point of view of the press are we
betraying the university press heritage
by doing things like undergraduate
research journals and putting our name
on them are we not are we wrong to put
our name on technical reports and that's
a that's a tricky one because we could
go over to our sort of a white label
approach and just say okay we're going
to provide the services but we're not
going to put our name on them but then
we again risk becoming irrelevant so
it's it's a it's a difficult one and I
think there is probably a similar
concern about some of the branding of
the libraries in an area where the
libraries are being sort of explicitly
commercial and but this comes over to
the question of business and
sustainability models and the issue of
when should we charge when should we say
this is mission related and I know I
think this is an area which will come up
again and again today how much of this
is mission related how much of this is
cost recovery I think what we hope will
happen is that we can move towards a
product mix where some things will be
subsidizing other things but at the
moment we're operating a lot of this on
short-term money and that really brings
up this issue of when the initial
funding comes along what will happen in
terms of these projects especially with
a complex project like a very central
will the library be carrying an unfunded
project and have to deal with it and
lastly
how do we define the limits of our
service are we just talking about
materials for faculty at Purdue or are
we actually providing larger services to
a larger community and this is an area I
think we're all facing as society
publishers come society's come to us
looking for publication solutions and I
think many of you will know about the
ARL project looking at the journals
rescue project as it's known looking at
how ARL libraries might support print
journals that want to transition to
online so you know what do we do with
these society journals are they within
our remit or not how do we prevent scope
creep so that's it thank you very much
so as my former professor Lisa pointed
out I have both a publishing background
and and a library degree and so this
project is really or this presentation
is really forcing me to think through
how those two things have come together
in my work life in the last few years at
NYU so I'm going to talk about what the
way we've organized digital publishing
at NYU and how we're managing certain
kinds of projects and different efforts
coming from both the libraries and the
press and where we hope that we're going
the context in why you as most of you
know is it's according to our website
the largest private university in the
country we have fifty-two thousand
students campuses now all over the world
increased that's and that's going to
continue a very large ARL library with a
pretty significant collections budget um
but our press is rather small we're
bigger than the purdue press we have 25
FTE at the press publish about a hundred
books a year we don't do any journals
and while you press is never published
journals so we don't have that expertise
which for a lot of places brings a lot
of digital expertise in with the journal
publishing we're really strictly a book
press and one
things that has I've discovered since I
took over this position is that in
addition to working with the libraries
in the press there's also really the
necessity of working with I TS so i ts
is part of our of our structure for how
we're providing digital publishing
services and one of the big pieces of
context for the way we're able to do
digital publishing is the this are the
sort of new tagline for nyu that we are
a global network university we have
established a campus in Abu Dhabi we're
establishing a second one in Shanghai
and these are not just study abroad
programs these are intended to be fully
fledged real NYU education is happening
around the world so there's an enormous
effort underway to figure out how to
provide research and teaching and
support all that globally not only from
NYU but not only from New York but
beyond so my position in the office of
digital scholarly publishing was created
I've been there about three and a half
years now not quite three and a half
years and it was explicitly intended to
be a link between the library in the
press so I have an office in both places
I report to the Dean of the library and
to the director of the press and I spend
an enormous amount of time doing
networking with IT s colleagues as well
as faculty and others at the University
who were really the people that are
bringing us a lot of the content that we
want to publish so I thought I'd try to
give you a sample of how our
organization looks and this is a very
schematic description of it but it gives
you some sense of sort of how were how
we're operating and how the human
relationships work so I am the little
the little ODSP office of digital
scholarly publishing at the bottom and I
report to the press and I report to the
library and the press also reports to
the library and then because we need
technology support that does not exist
in the press the press really doesn't
have the technology resources we rely on
D LTS the digital library technology
services which is part of the library
that has a dotted line report to I TS
which is the department in of its's edu
services that manages everything from
blackboard to email to all kinds of
strategic technology services
so there's you know a person in each of
these places who's talking to all the
other people at each of these places and
edu services also has a dotted line
report to the library so what the
structure suggests is in some ways that
there's there's a lot of sort of
separate organizations with each with
their own missions and goals and
priorities but that the human relations
among them are what's really kind of
keeping this going and and as the one
person who's really trying to link all
these conversations um I think that's
that's one of the things that makes our
organization really unusual is that I am
the one person tasked with making sure
these conversations continue I have a
lot of help with that and the people
that I'm talking to our certainly not
averse to it but it's my my job to sort
of drive that bus and that has its
challenges and partly because I can't I
can't know enough about what all those
other organizations are doing and
neither can they know enough about what
everybody else is doing so one of the
one of the responsibilities I realized
is that in addition to my communicating
I need to make sure that we have more
structure in place for everyone else to
communicate and that is making making a
real difference as we start to build in
that structure but as we created the
position we determined that essentially
it was going to sort of fall into three
kind of main categories of work so one
is that I'll be providing and figuring
out ways to provide library publishing
services just from within the library
and I'll be working just within the
press to help the press think
strategically about how to evolve from a
book print publisher into a publisher of
scholarship and rely on other technology
services to do that and then finally the
third piece is to bring the resources of
the press in the library together in
some ways that they haven't done before
so the priorities at the library were
really just to bring some publishing
expertise into the into the organization
nobody in the library had any specific
experience with publishing and that was
one of the reasons they wrote the Job
Description we're looking for someone
with both an MLS and a publishing
background and then we they wanted to
really start providing publishing
services so we've essentially in the
same ways some of the ways that Purdue
has done
we focus those in part on our
repositories and some journal publishing
services so we have we have a d space
repository the faculty digital archive
and that has been as Charles suggested
it's a challenge to get people to
contribute their own work to it so what
I've been focusing on our emphasis is
really to bring make it a resource for
both individual faculty members but also
departments and centers and Institute's
that have material that's difficult to
publish in other ways so really instead
of looking at getting faculty to give us
copies of their already published
articles what I'm looking for our
working papers and some conference
proceedings and various kinds of grey
literature research reports things that
need to be disseminated need to be
stored that are sort of scattered on web
sites around the campus now but that
could be more effectively made available
in our in our archive so that's the goal
and we're working at that with a number
of different colleges and groups around
the campus we're also just in the
process of starting to offer a service
of journal publishing using the open
source software open journal systems
which I know is used here at Columbia as
well and our first journal is coming out
of the school of education at Steinhardt
so those are two things that I manage
their our technology people who are both
in the librarian and its2 support them
and one of the challenges has been how
because we don't have digital Commons we
don't have a vendor off site who can
manage the technology issues we're
trying to figure out how do we upgrade
those services how do we create the
technology that we need using open
source software and provide the adequate
support so that's been a real open
ongoing conversation from within the
press one of the things that was clear
at the outset was that we weren't going
to suddenly drop our business model and
stop publishing books we really needed
to continue to sustain the business and
I think one advantage of my position is
that although I reports about the press
in the library I am on the you know in
the personnel world my salary is paid
out of the library budget I don't cost
the press anything so on some level I am
available to them I sort of expand their
bandwidth to think creatively and to
start strategically planning how they're
going to move into
future without needing to cover my costs
and I think that's made a big difference
in just sort of opening up that
conversation as at Purdue we have a
press that publishes a very specific set
of list because for good business
reasons you publish what you're good at
and you publish what you're known for
and what your strengths are in and at
NYU that's in the humanities and the
social sciences in about ten different
fields and some of them are strengths at
NYU and history and Media Studies
cultural studies law but and sociology
but NYU is an enormous comprehensive
research university and we couldn't
possibly publish in every field that's
important to NYU so that has led over
the years to a lot of frustration and I
don't believe the press is considered
irrelevant at the University but it's it
there's a lot of mystification about why
we would turn down things that so
clearly are about NYU why wouldn't we
publish a history of the physics
department for example you know there
are a lot of good reasons why you
wouldn't do that but it you have to have
that conversation over and over and over
so part of the reason for my position
was to build those start to be able to
provide publishing consultation and
advice that comes in some ways from the
press but doesn't require the press to
kind of come to the table as a publisher
in all ways the other thing that we
wanted to do is really be able to take
advantage of new opportunities and think
through how to do that so vendors and
technologies coming on stream pretty
much weekly we have to figure out how to
decide among those so part of my work is
talking with the managers at the press
about how we how we set our priorities
and how we go about doing that because
ultimately our goal is to be a scholarly
publisher regardless of format we want
to evolve into that where we may be a
book publisher but we may be supporting
all kinds of other things as well and
that's if we went ahead that way what do
we need to do to get there and as I said
one of our major partners is the
department in the library the digital
library technology services and some
background is useful here because when i
arrived at nyu they were just in the
beginning of a process of evolution from
being a essentially a project-based
grant funded you know they would get
money to do a specific project and build
technology as they needed it and they
were really trying to expand their tool
set and
their skill set but it was really
focused on where what they could get
money for and slowly they've been able
to provide more ongoing funding and
full-time staff that weren't just grant
funded and have evolved into a real
operation that wasn't their primary
focus when I arrived was really some
very significant preservation efforts
and digital preservation of formats that
are important at NYU and audio and video
television so they had some great
expertise in preservation but they
hadn't done large-scale digitization in
any way they hadn't done a lot of we
weren't digitizing our own collections
and they weren't really offering a whole
lot of ongoing access to stuff they
would build a website but it wasn't
really considered a publication in the
sense of how were people going to use
and reuse that material so these are the
departments that are on the slide that
they that they've now assembled
themselves into and it gives a lot more
opportunity for us to think about how
are we going to combine efforts and what
can we what can we do working with them
to figure out how to bring projects in
that the DLT s can help us build so I'll
give as Charles did a few examples of
specific things that we're working on
and I tried to sort of encapsulate what
they are and in some ways I think we're
really we're trying to find ways to
bring traditional scholars into the
digital realm we're also trying to work
really closely with innovative scholars
who are very very eager and pushing us
to do more in the digital realm and then
also really focusing on who the
publishing partners are at NYU that we
can work with most effectively both from
the press and the library side so the
first example we did was this came
directly out of the press an editor had
a book that was based on texts written
by authors who were representing
detainees at Guantanamo and they were
writing a book about it but they wanted
to provide access to the full text of
just in PDF form so this was seemed like
an obvious thing to do so we published
the press publish the book and the
library built a website and then it
turned out that the authors of the book
had an enormous additional archives in
print and in
digital form of all kinds of other
materials related to work at guantanamo
and they wanted to make that available
so that is an ongoing project in the
library special collections and so this
evolved nicely from you know a good way
to help an editor acquire a book that
the the authors wanted something more
than just a book so we were able to
offer that and then the library also
gained a very large and what we expect
to be a growing special collection over
time so that was just sort of a nice
indicator at the beginning first year
that we could the this sort of having
somebody in between the press and the
library was going to turn out to be
useful for a variety of reasons there's
one of the things that's been important
for us to bear in mind is how our
universities own large context can
influence what we're doing and the
presses worked for a long time to really
remind people at the lab at the
University that we you know we are
available to do publishing so one of the
exciting things that's happened with our
new campus in Abu Dhabi is a large
number of research grants have been
given and several of them have
explicitly listed the press as the
publisher of the works that are going to
be produced in that research so this is
the first one that's coming under way
it's the library of Arabic literature
which will be a 3.75 million dollar
grant over five years to translate
classical Arabic literature into English
and publish them in facing page
translations the way the loeb classical
editions are published or at NYU we did
this with the clay sanskrit library a
few years ago but we're also going to
have an online edition and we're still
discussing in what form that will take
so we're talking about in some ways very
very I mean there's sort of nothing more
sort of traditional to me than a
literature scholar very carefully
translating the texts of these in some
ways incredibly arcane works this is one
of those examples of when you realize
you don't know anything when you start
talking about what Arabic literature is
it's fascinating and incredibly diverse
so we're really trying to think about
how are we going to make that available
online who's the audience and the market
for it the library's also gotten some
money to scan works that we have in
Arabic in our library and we're working
with several other libraries in the
region so
be able to provide a library of those
scanned texts but then in addition to
that we want the scholars who were
working at these translations to have
the opportunity to work together in some
effective ways and to collaborate so the
global technology services group at NYU
which is building tools to help support
our global research university is we've
been talking to them about possibly
finding using these these scholars who
are scattered all over the world as a
test case for how we can link people
together as they're working and doing
their translations and coming up with
agreed-upon translations for certain
terms and other ways that that will
support their work together so they
aren't people these are not scholars who
are reaching out to us and saying hey we
want to do something really super groovy
they want to translate arabic but we
want to give them tools and use them as
test cases to to help us figure out how
to provide other kinds of groovy
services media Commons is a group that
we've been working with both from the
press in the library side who really
constitute the initiators of all kinds
of ideas these are a group of scholars
who are in media studies not all of them
are at NYU and initially we took this
over without them being at NYU one of
them was expecting to publish a book
with NYU press so this was kind of an
unusual library reaching out to support
scholarship that wasn't really
explicitly coming out of NYU there it's
a network of scholars who were working
in a variety of different forms and
they've we've built them a website and
essentially they're providing different
kinds of publishing and new news new
forms of scholarship and new genres and
asking for tools that will help support
that so just across the top there I can
describe these very briefly in media
races as a weekly sort of thematic in
some ways like a weekly magazine that
allows scholars to post a video clip and
describe it annotate it discuss it and
then there's a conversation that takes
place and that's essentially using a
simple blog software you can put
multimedia up and you can allow you can
allow conversation but they curate it in
such a way that every week has a
different theme and then people are able
to respond very quickly to changes in
the news because putting these things
online doesn't take any significant
amount of work and it doesn't go through
a peer-review process but then the the
different sets of discussions can be
used and have been used in classes and
in various ways people come back to them
and the conversations can continue the
new every day is a new related set of
scholarly conversations they form
clusters and what they're calling it is
a middle state publishing or it's not a
blog and it's not quite an article it's
the sort of people are starting to think
hard about a topic and they want to
discuss it with each other so media
Commons platform allows them to create a
cluster of conversations around these
particular topics and then have lots of
interactive conversation about those
finally the media Commons press is a
platform that enables essentially open
online peer review so books or journals
or edited collections can be posted in
this software called comment press and
people can comment on it on what evers
anyone who's online can join this
conversation and they can comment on a
paragraph by paragraph so the one
example we had of this was a book that
had been submitted to NYU press for
publication was simultaneously posted in
media Commons press and so the author
was getting traditional formal peer
review done at the press at the same
time as she was getting open online peer
review done by folks on this site and
was able to really benefit from those
two different forms of interaction the
goal that the media Commons scholars
have is really to start thinking about
new ways of publication that are more
open that give people credit for
commenting that give people give authors
the opportunity to directly engage with
their reviewers so what we're doing is
really trying to build tools to help
support that and so we're hoping to be
able to start doing more with open
annotation and we've just we hope very
soon in another week or two to receive a
grant that will let us bring a group of
scholars to NYU to talk about what peer
to peer review should be and how it
should work and what technologies are
needed to support it because we've
learned using media Commons Press that
it's not there are things we want to be
able to do that we can't do you
so we're hoping to specify what those
are and then really sort of push the
envelope and what what's accepted as
this form of scholarly communication so
is this new everyday kind of in-between
publishing something that eventually
will help people get tenure get
scholarly credibility the technology
work that's coming from this is coming
out of DLT yes the editorial director at
the press and I are very much engaged in
thinking about how do we promote these
events how do we how do we think about
evolving what the press does as a
publisher in relation to this and even
just things like the question of the
relationship between the book that the
press is going to publish in print and
as an e-book what's the relationship of
that to the book that appeared in media
Commons press that has been published it
will be a different version how are we
going to describe those two things and
relate them to each other so it's giving
us a lot of sort of examples that we
have to work through which is very very
useful the final example I have is from
our colleagues at the Institute for the
Study of the ancient world which is a
very well endowed Research Institute at
NYU and they have an extremely ambitious
plan to do digital publishing that's in
archaeology and classics that's really
rich and interlinked and very much takes
advantage of the digital so they can
publish materials with many many many
illustrations and lots and lots of
geographic data and links into all kinds
of existing databases but they also
wanted and they can do that with their
own resources there they have the
technology skills and the subject
expertise to create beautiful XML tagged
up stuff and present it online but they
realize that they also wanted to have a
press imprint a known publishers imprint
on that so they came to NYU press and
asked if we could provide that you know
co-publishing with them and that in some
of the ways that Charles was discussing
was a real question for the press about
how do we share our brand we had they
were going to be the experts this was
not a field that we publish in and we
didn't feel confident saying yeah we can
just give our imprint to those work so
we've had to come up with a solution for
their doing peer review us kind of
vetting the vetting of their peer review
and making sure that we're comfortable
and got a lot of advice from our
our own faculty advisory board on how
how to set that up in a way that would
allow us to share our imprint really for
the first time they're the folks that i
saw are also going to be working with
our colleagues at the digital library
technology services for some of the
technology that supports this and their
lee be doing a large set of scanned
texts that will support a lot of the
scholarship sort of a huge back list of
material that's important to the studies
in the ancient world is are going to be
scanned and made available through a
book reader that a browser reader that
our colleagues are published are working
on Indy LTS and that's a good example
for me that the book reader that they're
building for this purpose can be used
for the Arabic materials it can also be
used for the NYU press back list which
will eventually we've scanned all of our
backless books including some out of
print books and we'll be making those
available online not every book but a
significant number of them so the
technology that's coming from the
library is is going to be supporting the
press moving into some new ways and we
hope it will be relatively seamless so
this is back to my organizational chart
and I just I added the cloud at the top
because I really have the sense that
this this is what we're going to be able
to do in the ways we're going to the
decisions we make and the priorities
that are driving us are also coming from
the sign of overarching set of other
people that are NYU's own institutional
directions there are individual faculty
member there are people out there and in
some cases they've you know reigned
funds on us we don't normally get part
of a 3.75 million dollar grant at the
press that was that was a lot of money
for us you don't get all of it but that
so that that big cloud can produce an
enormous amount of potential for us but
it also can you know bring in challenges
and expectations and requirements that
we hadn't set up ourselves so the
question of scope mission creep is
really critical for us as well so for me
these are the things that we need to do
most effectively next really start to
articulate the shared visions and goals
of all the different partners in this
relationship I'm never going to be able
to stop with that you know everybody
needs to communicate all the time which
is
sting but important and then really we I
think rather than set up a really
concrete set of exactly what we need to
be doing we just need to keep
experimenting for a while and then
eventually develop some structures that
as we need them i think the way we've
set it up where I'm this kind of the one
of my colleagues calls me the ligature
between the press and the librarian to
some extent to I TS as well I mean
ligature is it uncomfortable metaphor
for me because I have a feeling and
ligature can snap but but it's also you
know it really is a link I need I need
to be the one who who can bring these
these conversations together and I also
need to build the relationships that I'm
have with the people i'm having
conversations with so that they can
converse with each other more so that's
part of the communication is really
building building the network of folks
in the conversation so that's the end of
my killing me the perils are the
benefits of the final speaker that
you'll either say I've heard all this or
what a beautiful summation i think you
will hear many echoes of what my
colleagues have said here which is not
entirely coincidental we've spoken
together on several other occasions and
I think we benefit from each other's
counsel and wisdom and example as was
mentioned earlier i'm the associate
university librarian for publishing at
the University of Michigan library which
is I think currently a position unique
among research libraries it's the
functional equivalent associate dean i'm
not sure what your terms are here at
columbia at Barnard and I'm responsible
for a broad portfolio of publishing and
publishing related services and i'm here
today to talk to you about organization
not just in the sense of our org chart
but in the broad sense of the word of
how we organize our publishing capacity
our skills and our tools to support the
work of the university and with that in
mind I'd like to step back for a minute
and talk a little bit about the work of
the University this is a the mission
statement from my university to serve
the people of Michigan and the world
through preeminence in creating
communicating preserving
applying knowledge art and academic
values and developing leaders and
citizens who will challenge the present
and enrich the future and I want to
focus on what I see is at the core I
mean it's literally at the center of
this communicating and preserving
because this is where I see the work of
libraries and publishers and I think
it's interesting that it is located at
the heart of the academic mission and
also that they're integrally tied
together so if this is the work of
expressing the scholarly conversation
the great khali conversation happens
across time in space and that needs to
happen through our publishing mechanisms
and through our preservation mechanisms
which makes the library a really
interesting place to bring together the
various publishing components of the
university and I think this is important
to consider when we think about the work
of the university that in essence if we
don't communicate our scholarship we
might as well not be doing it and the
Academy really needs to look after the
expression of its work or its work is
worth nothing and this need was the
motivation for my library and my
university to prioritize an investment
in publishing and our goal is to is to
build and create and creating a
publishing division within the
university library is to build a center
for publishing support and a place to
think holistic and strategically about
publishing and how it helps achieve our
institutional goals I do see this as a
necessary direction for research
institutions I think publishing is
absolutely integral to the academic
enterprise but we often tend not to
think strategically about it and while
we've invested very heavily in the
services and the infrastructure to
support the actual research and the
production of the scholarship when it
comes to the publication of the
scholarship we often think the market
will take care of it and in many areas
the market fails us for a lot of
different reasons in communicating Scott
scholarship
so let me talk about about one sense of
organization which is the institutional
reporting relationships through which we
manage our staff and their work so in
the beginning well really about two
years ago there were a sort of several
centers of publishing and publishing
related activity going on at the
University they were scattered around
the campus but they were increasingly
concentrated in the library however
without any real coordination the unit
which I was the director of formerly the
scholarly publishing office reported to
the dean of libraries and almost through
happenstance one of our other sort of
content creation units the text creation
partnership reported to me but was not
related to the scholarly publishing
office our institution repository deep
blue reported to her aul for library
information technology and the
university of michigan press reported to
the dean of the graduate school in july
of 2009 the University of Michigan moved
the press from the oversight of the
Graduate School to within the library
Charles talked about that moves them a
little bit and this created an education
for discussion of how we best manage to
the library approaches the library's
approach to publishing so when I came
into the position I was handed as new
managers are an org chart and this
brought together several of these units
into one publishing portfolio and so
here's what it looks like and it's quite
tidy and each of the units is within its
own box and this is very much how they
operated they were occupied with their
own projects they were friendly
occasionally collaborative occasionally
competitive but essentially
self-contained I'm and my my mission has
been to mess that all up and to break
out to break open the boundaries that
contain those various kinds of
publishing activity
so what I've been interested in is
creating a central organization that
supports a variety of kinds of
publishing in which there's a great deal
of interchange and overlap so oh my
Daisy isn't isn't displaying nicely here
it's really quite beautiful the colors
are very nice but so what I'm interested
in is really what happens at the core
and we still have a lot of investment in
what I call the petals the things that
are on the outside but I see these as
need and demand driven and able to were
able to grow new pedals in response to
new needs or as much as my staff hates
it when I say it we're able to pluck off
old ones when they're no longer
necessarily or maybe would they would do
they wither and drop as they're no
longer necessary but at the heart of
this we have this core of expertise and
attention to the publishing needs of the
University so what is M publishing it's
a suite of imprints and services
dedicated to publishing and preserving
the scholarly record and as I said it's
the location and organization of a
variety of publishing mechanisms that
serve the needs of the institution and
the Academy and I think of that as the
Academy with the capital a not just not
just my institution but the scholarly
Academy cliff Lynch the director of the
Coalition for networks information
recently described this as not in
publishing but what he saw as a need for
publishing in the universe in the future
as a portfolio of strategies to support
the communication and documentation of
scholarship and what we're trying to
achieve within that center is
essentially building services and
infrastructure to support publishing to
develop a program of education and
advocacy around publishing and
publishing related issues at the local
and national level I'm end to actually
publish and that is certainly less but
not but not least that we believe that
we need to invest in the in this
production and dissemination of
scholarship in ways that we can find
Sicily sustainable and supportable so
that sounds pretty good but I'd like to
stop to consider what what is this
publishing of which I speak exactly so
I'd like to turn to that question for a
while and briefly interrogate our
notions of what constitutes publishing
um because I think that what happens in
our institutional and organizational
discussions around publishing is that we
often come to them with an inherited and
unselfconscious idea of publishing but
they may be quite different depending on
who's who's at the table and that
creates stress points in our in our
discussions I'll let you contemplate
this for a minute i should i should have
charles say publishing and then i could
say it so we can see what these
pronunciations actually sound like but
you can see that you know even you know
you never let somebody have access to
the OED right there's a range of
dictionary definitions of publishing
from the very simple to make public to
creating and I like the fact that has
become through the medium of the printer
the int or Internet and the OED to make
generally accessible or available for
acceptance or use to present to or
before the public but there's a bundle
of activities that support publishing
and I think there's a kind of range or
spectrum where from one part of simply
putting something on the web is an act
of publication to a very complex set of
interrelated activities that result in
publication um and I think if you talk
to most people who have worked in the
publishing industry they'll say that
it's a whole range of activities that
are linked and necessarily so that's the
way in which our business structures
have grown up to support all of these
the range from the acquisition of the
content through a selection and
solicitation process through all the
steps most of you are familiar with
going through review editorial
development editing and proofreading
actually getting the material into shape
marketing and promoting it having the
mechanisms to sell it if necessary and
then to actually deliberate it to the
user but what I would posit is that
publishing is actually a bundle of
activities that can be combined
separated and recombined in many
configurations and I think Monica and
Charles have pointed to some of the ways
in which that can be done that they can
be outsourced store done in-house and
they can be done independently through a
single author or creator they can be
done through a set of coordinate
services or they can be done through a
single multifunctional organization and
that's okay but that what we need to do
is to think about how we meet weather
weather there we need to do all of those
things in what cases we need to do those
things and then how we meet the needs so
put more simply like what it is is up to
us so I think those of us who are in the
position of creating new kinds of
publishing mechanisms and in taking
advantage of what technology and
networks in communication has to offer
us in terms of assisting with publishing
need to ask ourselves some questions and
I think if we work with that list I put
up before again we say do these things
need to be done in some cases maybe yes
every single one of these steps needs to
to be done in order to meet the
communication needs the scholarly
communication needs of that particular
genre who will do it how do we what
staff do we direct toward this what
parts of the organization and we have to
ask how will support this activity and
there are variety of ways but in which
we can do that either through directing
existing resources looking for new
resources or through some kind of cost
recovery and or through sales of the
resulting products again I don't think
that any one of these answers is
privileged but that it's more a matter
of assessing the need and figuring out
how to meet it so I just want to give
one example today which is our
University of Michigan faculty reprints
this is a new service that is not not
not all that high impact yet we hoped
and it's not it broadly used but it's
been much appreciated so for the faculty
reprint service we make available to
faculty whose works have gone out of
print at other places we put them online
and back into print for them
in most in most cases when this has
happened the faculty member has already
reclaimed the rights but we can also
assist them in investigating the right
situation and helping to reclaim those
rights if they need to this is just a
little bit of it comes from our handout
that we give to faculty who are
interested that talks about how we get
it started so it's one of the one of the
reprints in the hot seat trust we we put
that I'll speak talk about this more in
a moment we put them online both and
know how to trust our digital digital
library in our institutional repository
so I'd like to go back to that that list
of components of publishing that I put
up before and just talk about the
faculty reprint service in that light so
how do we get these books well we set up
a selection principle which is pretty
pretty simple you're a faculty member of
the University of Michigan and you have
a previously published book to which you
own the rights we don't believe that we
have a need for review editorial
development or editing and proofreading
since those have been done with the
original text much of the design is in
the existing book but because we do
allow for some extra material the
authors often write a new introduction
or may provide some supplemental
materials and we need to design covers
we worked on templates to create those
to minimize the cost and this was
supplied by the by and publishing the
actual production is managed by in
publishing the marketing and promotion
of these reprints is a kind of effort
where everybody brings to the table what
we can the author usually does some some
work on that and his or herself and
publishing makes an effort to make
announcements about the book let the
campus community know let the department
if we are we work with the author to
target list serves blogs places where
people won't want to know this book is
available again and make contact about
that I mean we also pole in our subject
librarians in the area of the subject
area of the reprint and ask them to tap
their library networks and their
scholarly networks just to let people
know that this book is available again
the sales are handled pretty simply the
only place they're for sale is Amazon
and direct through us although we are in
discussions about how the university of
michigan press can provide distribution
services for the faculty reprints as
well in terms of fulfillment again
through amazon also through our espresso
Book Machine at the library will produce
local copies which has been useful in
printing up books for classes for
example at a reasonable price and again
potentially we could do this through the
press online they're available through
deep blue and how to trust and there it
is on Amazon and in addition to the
services that I've mentioned we also
provide a network of support for the
reprints we do contractual review and
termination assistance provided by the
copyright office if the author needs
help in seeking permissions on embedded
materials we give them guidance on that
we don't actually do that permission
seeking ourselves but again we provide
them with templates and we help them to
locate the rights holder if we can do
that and digitization services to get a
digital copy of the book if they don't
have an electronic copy and even source
copies because in one case even the
author did not have a copy of her book
we are provided by the library but my
point in this is that each one of these
pieces is a relatively small
contribution from an area of the library
and I think what's interesting is the
way in which that we've been able to
combine them to create a new kind of
service it's not a perfect way to work
and I don't and I don't want to to
indicate that it is and with each each a
new service that we're trying to provide
there's a substantial effort that goes
into defining shaping and communicating
about that service and because we are
drawing upon many locations of work
throughout the library the coordination
costs can be high and it's also hard
sometimes to tell the difference between
when we're doing something just as a
one-off and when it's the first of its
kind and that was certainly true with
the faculty reprint series that i put up
here there was one person who came to
us and said can you help me do this and
it seemed like a good thing to do and we
defined what we wanted to do and said
you know we should really offer this
more broadly and so far it looks like
there will be some uptake on this we've
got six books after six months that
we've put back back and it's not been
broadly advertised yet and we have
several more expressions of interest but
that was a chance that we took that what
about whether there would be an appetite
for this or not it's also can be
challenging to balance a service
orientation and meeting the immediate
needs of people who come to us with a
publishing problem or need for
publishing capacity and being proactive
in our programmatic development and
deciding internally well where do we
think things are going and how can we
take the time to shape a proper service
and also in doing this kind of
coordinated configuration of
configuration of parts to support
publishing sometimes a product or
publication doesn't have a particular
champion we're handing it off from one
piece to another and nobody's looking
after it through the whole scope from
the moment we begin to talk about the
project to when it appears online and in
print and this form of so this form of
organization can complicate that and
it's something we're trying to address
in sort of assigning advocates managers
to every kind of publication making sure
that that's happening but it's that's an
additional demand on on our people so I
wanted to leave you with this which has
nothing at all to do with publishing but
it's up on the wall of my office I was
from a company called indie furniture I
was looking for a storage solution for
my five year olds room and they have
furniture that comes in that shelving
that comes in components and you can put
it together in all kinds of interesting
ways and i love that what they have
online to plan your furniture is called
the configurator because i say i often
think of the work that we're doing as
being a kind of new configuration to
support scholarly publishing we have a
lot of pieces and we're trying to work
in collaboration and in helping to do
planning and sometimes helping people to
do themselves what we can't do for them
by providing referrals and console
asian and and resulting in my favorite
part of this a highly reconfigurable
structure to support to support
publishing so thanks um so are there any
questions for the panel and if you have
one could you go up to the microphone
and if not they're gonna hear from me
okay then that hopefully this will
prompt some people but so all of you are
working trying to pull together a
communication communication
communication as you all suggested but
you're all working on a variety of
projects so how are those how do you
sort those out you bring all the people
to the table I mean just just walk us
through kind of your process for the
decision making for which projects you
take on and who gets to make what call
and it's kind of a vaguely worded
question intentionally for you well I
think one of the interesting questions
here is is the role of the faculty
member and point that Maria made about
is this a one-off resist to start for
service I mean yeah there's this this
term that's used around at the
university of charismatic megafauna
which I like because it expresses a
certain type of faculty member who's
willing to push push the envelope so you
know in decision making around projects
and doing new types of things it's
crucial to us that we're working with
them with intellectual with content
providers and and intellectual champions
who are easy to work with and who have
have good ideas and that's not a very
scientific way of making decisions
between probe between projects but I
think it's a really good one and I
remember a project which was
it was a big archaeology project that i
was on the fringes of at one stage and
their policy there their secret for
success was Katie AO and they put it up
on the PowerPoint presentation and yeah
I said what is Katie AO and they said
it's kicked the assholes out so that's
that question is I think central to what
I've been experiencing moving from the
publishing world to the library world
where in publishing an enormous amount
of the energy of any publishing
organization is spent precisely on
deciding what you're going to publish
and you you have a very very clearly in
a good publishing house a clearly
articulated sense of what it is that you
do and what it is that you don't do and
then when you decide you're going to do
it what happens after that the whole
thing is clear and well-defined and on
some level rigid which is why people
have been struggling working with a lot
of university presses who have rigid
structures because they know how much
they cost and how long it takes and that
that whole process was very very
comfortable and familiar to me that we
knew what to do and how to do it and we
knew what we didn't do and in library
publishing and in digital technology
projects in general it's very much
harder um they at NYU what we tend to do
is you know if someone's really
advocating for something you know we we
don't have a really form formal
structure yet as you could probably tell
from my slide with all those different
arrows there isn't a hierarchy yet and
one of the things I think I need to work
on is getting a hierarchy in place so we
can start to really assess this big
stream of work versus this versus this
and how are we going to bring it
together we have a lot of the
charismatic megafauna issue people come
in the door with funding or with
reputation or with something super cool
and I you know energy gets directed that
way um but when I first started talking
to them about this job I remember I said
to Steve makowsky who's the director of
the press um so how do you think that
dual reports going to work i'll report
to you and I'll report to Carol and he
said yeah and I also report to Carol so
if there's a really big
disagreement Carol wins and in some way
i found that comforting a that there
were going to be disagreements and be
that there was going to be you know
somebody who's going to make the call so
we're still sort of in that and we don't
have a lot of fights but eventually the
hierarchy does sort of take over and
that's you know useful to know oh yeah i
guess i've been thinking about that
hierarchy a bit too and what the
creation of my position did that we
didn't have before because these units
did exist before and spent a lot of time
over the course of many years like
trying to figure out how to how do we
work together or how can we and always
sort of agreeing that they shared a
sense of wanting to advance the
scholarly mission and contribute to that
so there is some value in now we have my
managers meetings and we all sit down
every two weeks and talk through these
things and at some point i say okay yes
so that's that's one way we are putting
in place some other structures for the
projects that arise sort of out of the
campus or external organizations that
want to work with us we have an
application process in place that has a
number of criteria partly for it but to
help us assess their readiness to work
with us how much have they thought about
this and that also looks at funding and
fit with mission from so that gets
reviewed a couple of times a year but i
don't want to pretend that things don't
trump that and the things that probably
trumpet are a really powerful faculty
member who may have a funding source who
comes in and says i'm on fire and let's
do this thing and usually talks to my
boss the dean of libraries is this is
great how can we support this and then
you know we figure out how to do that
and the other thing because we are do
continue to need to find a lot of our
activities is that there are things with
significant revenue opportunities that
sort of might get in the mix and
anyway so no perfect answer I'm really
interesting talking about the
sustainability and especially for
academic publishing and we know this is
not profitable but how you helped the
publish it I have a risk in the case
when of my librarians working within our
library find some rare resources in our
collection they weren't published by
that Columbia University Press however
Columbia University Press asking
contributing you know we need to find
the money ourselves the librarian we
don't have money and the out my library
spent a lot of time talking to each
faculty is there any way in you think
it's more you know the financial way to
sustain to help for the academic
publishing I mean to me I also like a
little shocked in my life is docking run
everywhere looking for money because the
cream be oppressed asking for seven
thousand dollars to publish a book it's
like
Bree said that that in the past the
universities and faculty would work on
creating the scholarship doing the
research and then the market would take
care of the situation it would get out
there would be disseminated because
there was a market for it and now for
certain quite narrow projects where we
only can expect to sell about 200 copies
the market doesn't take care of it
anymore and that's why these
collaborations could you know are I
think mushrooming and are great if you
do if you can take out the if you can
get the funding in some other way and
take out the market as part of your
thinking about getting the scholarship
out there that's the only way they're
going to work and they're only going to
come from this kind of I think
collaboration where there's the economic
model is just not the way it was in the
old days when we could sell enough books
to cover the costs roughly well well I
guess I've had a three-pronged strategy
and its ongoing work believe me on this
is that I think that publishing doesn't
have to cost us as much as it has cost
us and that we have an opportunity to
constrain those costs and that
technology is useful in that and so that
it's incumbent upon people who are doing
doing the publishing to look for ways to
constrain the cost but that it's also
incumbent on the institution to
recognize that it does cost money and I
think one of the things libraries have
been grappling with as those was the
percent 70 70 something percent of
libraries that have started to engage in
publishing is that it means dedicating
resources and it's usually something
more than just hiring a person to do
some to do some programmatic development
that they do have to shift resources
toward that and so libraries have to
think about that and then the third part
is that the institution has to think
about its responsibility to support the
cost of publishing and those of us who
are doing it need to bet make a better
case
to the institution about why that that's
true and it keep having those
conversations so that for me that's the
kind of long-term answers like we work
on all three parts of that and then we
might get to a healthier more
sustainable publishing environment just
one point of that I'm something that
said that really struck me moving as i
did in 2009 from a small private
nonprofit publisher to a large research
institution is that there's an awful lot
of money that's poorly spent within
large universities around the issues of
communicating scholarship and
communicating scholarship but also
communicating other things which are
maybe less scholarly and strategically
if the library composition itself as an
organization that knows how to do things
within workflows and get the stuff out
there and measure impact and measure
usage and that sort of thing which is
not hard it's not too hard to do because
the library does have a lot of those
skills in it then there's actually a
quite a lot of money washing around
there are quite a lot of resources which
just can be better harnessed so that's
really struck me I also was really
struck moving from the publishing world
into the library world with that money
that's washing around I mean it in a in
a normal publishing house you know
exactly what you're spending and with
innovative kind of new projects in the
digital realm it's very very very hard
for libraries to understand what they
actually cost so when I hear people say
things like well we've got all these
online journals using you know open
source software and it's all free I want
to throttle them because it isn't free
it's costing money in an enormous number
of unaccountable ways that haven't had
to be documented yet and publishers who
are working within a very explicit
budget constraint are really required to
document everything they spend and
everything they give they bring in so
university presses can often seem rigid
because they can say we need seven
thousand dollars they know exactly what
they need and libraries very often can't
say that I mean they may be able to say
it for certain kinds of things but I
think part
that sustainability conversation has to
be a willingness to really assess what
the actual costs are and what it's going
to take to keep that going which is in
some ways what Murray is trying to work
out
I can repeat the question so the
question was how does the espresso Book
Machine fit into the equation are you
all familiar with this machine so it's a
book making machine and it said that
Prince books on demand you have to have
a digital file once the digital file is
set up it takes about five minutes to
produce the one off of a book and does
it pretty pretty cheaply direct costs
are about penny a page including the
cover and then there of course they're
operator costs and things like that
associated with it but we you know we
sell these books that we participated
between six and ten dollars when we sell
them in the library and I think for me
it's just it's a piece of the toolkit
all right so it meets the need for for
local printing some of the ways in which
we've used it that have been interesting
to me are a professor who's authoring a
textbook and working it out with his
students so now we're on his third
iteration of the textbook he adjusted
every semester and then we turn around
and produce a new a new very short run
and sell it directly the students from
the library as he works toward the final
version of it I get a bill of you to put
some older older works back into print
to support education so I think it's
there are services that do what the
espresso Book Machine doesn't mean
there's Lulu and blur banana bird print
on demand on services but by putting it
in the library and connecting it with
people who help think about the
publishing strategy for a particular
book it becomes a pretty valuable tool
can I just make comments yes I
understand that the publishing you know
they needed their estimate you know cost
but also i'm thinking we can work in
library we can welcome its publishing
the press like for this book i know the
project you mentioned and we know
there's a big market outside us in china
and we can introduce you the publishers
vendors in china hong kong and there can
maybe sell the your books they cut in
the cost that's the possibility in a
because we can do meet the Chinese
published invited like 10 biggest east
asian library director to China free you
know chip to talk to the Chinese
publishers and anything published about
China in u.s. especially material they
have not seen they are really interested
to you know whatever work with that so
I'm willing to working with that I mean
I enjoyed this is a model that you'd
library and the press walking together
and I really enjoy that yeah I'm gonna
encourage gym and Jennifer to have a
conversation uh any anybody else well
thank you very much panel and thanks for
everyone for coming and our next event
is on the sixth of April right here in
this very room and I hope you all come
back thank